[Music]
so what do you then do in the cases
where your religious belief and secular
society don't match up and you're taking
into account what you just said about
not trying to legislate everything so I
think gay marriage is probably the best
example of this something that is now
legal in America that is a would you say
it's against the biblical teachings is
that a fair way to yeah that's fair way
to cure it that's a very fair way to
characterize it so how do you deal with
something like that we have to go
case-by-case I suppose I mean do a
clearer example maybe is is abortion so
if the right to life is the most
fundamental attack on innocent human
life is the most outrageous moral
problem then the church you know I think
properly recognizes that is so
fundamental the church also would see
for example masturbation is morally
problematic we're not going to legislate
against masturbation so there's the
acquaintance principle if something is
so fundamental to the right ordering of
society that legislating against it is
called for then by all means if it would
cause problems so enormous on the other
side well then prudence dictates that
you shouldn't legislate against it so
that's always the principle has to be
applied in all these cases yeah so let's
actually go with all three of those
because I think they're they're all
hot-button once people want your
feelings on each one so in the case of
abortion you're saying it's at such a
high level basically because you're
dealing with human life that this is
something that should be illegal so so
the argument is that at the moment of
conception that's where life begins mhm
well we could amplify it in different
ways too you know yeah but that is the
argument that's oh yeah okay we start
disrespecting human life in that
fundamental way the very moral
foundation of a society collapse and
that will manifest itself in all sorts
of ways so I think we've recognized that
quite properly as so fundamental that we
have to legislate against there it's
wise for the Society for that to be
prescribed legally yeah so what do you
do in all the murky cases that everyone
talks about so a 16 year old girl is
raped violently does not want to have
the child it's three days after the
event do you see some distinction there
yeah there is certainly a at the
psychological level of
we'd recognize the difference there when
you come though to the moral issue you
know why would the child have to be the
victim of that the further victim of
that situation why would the child have
to be as it were eliminated to solve
that problem
murky yes problematic yes
psychologically difficult of course but
the moral issue remains the same that
child has no less dignity than someone
conceived another way so the church
would still make that strong statement
yeah that child should be respected is
there an instance where science could
change the Church's teachings in other
words if if there was flat-out science
that could be handed to you that said
well actually although the egg meets the
sperm at day one but actually what we
believe now and what we can factually
prove now is life doesn't begin for two
months that the first two months are the
primordial stew but there's not the
essence of life if that could be proven
to you could that change your position
on this well but we hard to imagine
science unsane what it said about human
DNA at that level and so if that's
present I think it's hard to avoid
inclusion we're dealing with human life
questions of consciousness and all that
is personally tied to consciousness I
think are much more derivative the
fundamental fact is you're dealing with
at the biological level at the most
fundamental way human life so I mean
it's hard for you to imagine science
gained saying that in some ways I would
argue we're staying with the science
I mean we're worse thing was something
that Thomas Aquinas wouldn't have seen
for example Thomas would have seen in
Solman happening later we press it now
because of science in a more radical
direction yeah do you ever think that
some of these can be just a net loss for
the church even if even if you're taking
what you believe to be the moral and
correct position that if X amount of
people and this will also can also
transition us to gay marriage but if 60
percent of the country says or 60
percent of your own congregation says
well I'm actually for pro-choice or I'm
for gay marriage that you are ultimately
you're playing a losing game even with
your own people even if you're your
moral position you
is completely tenable yeah but we can't
play it that way because then you're
doing evil the good might come of it if
you say well we'll do this because we'll
get more people think of Jesus in the
Gospel of John announcing the doctrine
of the real presence what he said might
my flesh is real food my blood is real
drink they all left everyone left except
his disciples he goes well you're gonna
leave too and Peter says well no you've
got the words of everlasting life in
other words they were playing a numbers
game they weren't saying only better
better back off that teaching because
the people are gonna go I'll give you
you know whenever we get too sexual
things I like to to at least make a
comparison to another moral area the
church has got a very strong teaching
about Just War the Just War Theory you
know there are certain criteria have to
be met to justify going to war then
other criteria have to be met to justify
how we conduct the war right my judgment
if you really apply those teachings
there's never been a just war even World
War two you might say sure going to war
it could be justified but Dresden the
fire bombings of Frankfurt and Tokyo the
atomic bombs those are radically immoral
for on Catholic grounds because we call
for discrimination between combatants
and non-combatants
we call those that are tactical things
well yeah the war itself you would say
is just let's say in the case of world
war ii yeah i'll maybe grant you that
going to war yeah you could just fight
the kind of the war absolutely not
now my point is if you had polled
catholics let's say in 1945 where we
justifying dropping the atomic bombs 98
percent i bet would have said yeah poll
catholics today say well we justify
dropping italian went fire bombing
Dresden
I bet 97 but I would say yes okay that
we better dial down or teaching that we
better dial down that just war teaching
and say and if you brought a lot of
generals into the room I bet they'd say
you know father that's great but you
priests are naive about you know how war
is conducted it
this is totally idealistic unrealistic
should we therefore dial down the Just
War teaching no cuz we're calling people
to a radical sanctity it's a high bar on
purpose we don't dial down the ideals
because people a find them difficult
they'll walk away because of them and I
think now apply it back to sexual
matters it's a similar situation the
church is extreme in its demand and now
I'm gonna play the Pope Francis card and
now cynically because the church plays
both cards it's extreme in its demand
because it wants his people to be Saints
not mediocrities extreme in its demand
at the same time it's extreme in its
mercy so a mass murderer comes to the
confessional and he says bless me Father
for I have sinned
I've murdered 25 people are you contrite
yes I I'm contrite about it do you
resolve never to do that again yes the
proper response to the priest is i
absolve you from all your sins in the
name of the Father Son and Holy Spirit
in other words the church offers a
radical mercy that is the balance if you
want to the radical demand that's one
way of getting at some of the heart a
stuff yeah so I want to get to a couple
other things but in that specific case
so someone comes in yeah murder 25
people you know i absolve you of that is
the is the where's the legal onus oh
that's a whole different question yeah I
mean you as a confessor would let's say
the guy has not surrendered to the plate
right of course surrender to the police
of course and now go to jail for the
rest of your life but I mean does the
priest have a legal
I guess the priest does have a legal
risk there's nothing within a church
that would or is there something no on
the church I can't break the seal of
confession but you could you should
indeed say to the person let's say they
have not sir of course surrounding the
police of course take all the justice
coming to you from the law but the point
there is from the church's perspective
the forgiveness of God is offered in
this lavish way and the church is mercy
toward all of us and ci here's where you
never want to be up on the pedestal like
all you people need to get in line
I'm the worst sinner I mean I fall short
of the Church's teaching all the time
and so we're we're reliant upon the
divine mercy at every minute even as we
call ourselves and others to a kind of
heroic virtue yeah is there some
slippery slope there like if someone
went into a therapist you know a
psychologist and said I've murdered 25
people and they said Billy do you feel
bad do you
repent and all that stuff and the guy
said yeah I'm pretty sure that legally
the therapist would have to go to the
authorities like if they were
threatening to kill them right but
that's not I think so I understand that
it's not the same as that you're right
but in a weird way the church is getting
a real bonus a real governmental bonus
there in a way right someone can come in
for absolution yeah get it and now the
person who now has this information
doesn't have to do anything with it that
that seemed like a bit of a boondocks
why wouldn't you know but I wouldn't
phrase it that way I mean he can't do
something with it because the way a
confession is understood by the church
and the state that's one thing but a
perspective that you know right so but
that's what I'm saying so the the church
is getting a little bonus there that a
secular I suppose a therapist wouldn't
get right but the church men in question
would still be obliged of course to tell
that person to to surrender and to
accept legal justice in all its
ramifications so it's not like a
get-out-of-jail-free card
confession it's a it's a promise of the
divine mercy that comes to you in a
lavish way now having said that should
you go to jail for the rest of your life
yeah yeah probably right and that's a
different different adjudication yeah
okay so now let's move to the other two
examples that you mentioned so gay
marriage yeah so I don't know how much
googling you did on me before you got
here but I am gay married you are in my
house right now I've thoroughly enjoyed
talking to you this entire time
actually when I was doing research on
you I got to the you know gay marriage
portion I stopped reading because I
don't know your full opinion and I did
not want to know before we sat down so
now I welcome you to to tell me that and
and whatever you say I will continue
this conversation ya know the spirit
which I've done it so far right and I'd
say several things I said this one time
I was in New York with cardinal Dolan
actually and we were talking to
reporters and I said if the only thing a
gay person hears from the Catholic
Church is you're intrinsically
disordered we got a very serious problem
on our hands if that's what the message
has become the mess of the church to a
gay person should be you are a beloved
child of God who's been embraced by the
mercy of Jesus Christ and invited to a
full share in the divine life
you're you're a son of God called to
eternal life
there's message 1 now within that are
there further specifications to be made
about anyone's moral life I mean my
moral life needs a lot of work trust me
you know and I need to hear a lot of
challenge from the church but we'll do
confession it yeah that's your words
yeah the words we'll have a good
conversation about that ya know but the
first thing that a gay person like any
person should hear is your beloved child
of God and so I agree with those and
Pope Francis Meagher on this but have
said if that's the way our message was
coming out
we were disordered you know I'm saying
we had a problem there and the way that
message was being conveyed what's the
church's take that sexuality has a has a
structure and intelligibility that's
built into it if you will by God and is
discernible within our physical
psychological and spiritual makeup it's
got a proper end and purpose the church
would say it's for intimacy and for
procreation therefore that's the fully
integrated properly expressed form of
sexuality when we fall short of that I
say we on purpose I mean we all
different ways I think fall short of
that ideal including married people the
church says no to that in a certain way
I don't trust the church says no -
there's no - whatever that imperfection
is whatever that failure fully to
integrate the meaning of sexuality you
see in a certain way I wouldn't want to
press it further than that
that's the church's job is to say no to
what it perceives to be an inadequate
incomplete integration of the sexual act
so not just gay marriage but now go
across the board anything that falls
short of that ideal the church would
would say no - why because it's down on
people as puritanical at hate sex
no it's keeping its bar high and calling
people always to that bar as we all fall
short of it the church offers at its
best
the lavish mercy of God
I mean that's sort of the context I try
to set for that conversation right so so
I understand the church's bar on this
yeah that's that's I'm not part of the
church it's it's fun for the church to
have that bar I have no problem with
that so your personal feelings on this
matter so gay marriage was passed what
is it a year and a half ago or so yeah
those two years now
did you I assumed you felt it was the
wrong decision by the court is that is
that fair to say I don't want to put
words in your mouth yeah no I do but I
don't think I would want to press it
much further I think where we are right
now in the states I'll apply the Aquinas
principle I think it would probably
cause much more problem in dissension
and difficulty if we kept pressing it so
then do you not see gay marriage as one
of the ones that you said was so
pressing earlier when you said that
abortion would be one that is so
pressing yeah that it could shift you
could alter the course of a country or
something do you not see gay marriage at
that level of City no I do think it does
have a negative impact on the wider
society I do think it is a in a certain
way a compromising or undermining of an
institution that's key to the health of
a society can you explain that if so
just as the dignity of individual is
fundamental morally so I think marriage
we've classically seen as the great
building block of the wider society so
all the different forms of social life
are grounded finally in that fundamental
form of social life so marriage open to
children is that form and society I
think takes that as one of its
foundational elements so I do think
there's a compromising if we if we
forget the integrity of that that
foundation yeah is this one of the
things where I sense that your heart and
your your spiritual sense itself maybe
aren't quite matched up because I I
don't sense judgment from you see yeah I
really don't yeah and I don't sense that
you want do that you would try to
legislate to reverse the decision but I
also sense that you can't fully say to
me well it's it's okay
yeah I know and that's probably right
the way you just put it there's pie
right right I wouldn't want to fully
just say that's great off you go yeah at
the same time I wouldn't want to get
into a
a Crusaders tank and try to reverse that
and I certainly don't want gay people to
have the impression that the church is
you know in some kind of special warfare
against them it's not the church is at
his best is reaching out in love and
reaching out with the offer of the
divine life that's what matters so I
feel strongly about that you know yeah
alright so we'll do the one other that
you mentioned out of these three and
then we'll move on to some other stuff
so you mentioned porn
I have watched porn obviously I think
probably everyone is watched porn I
think almost everyone that's watch porn
would Bali's any watch too much boring
but what's your basic take on again it's
a it's a legal act so again we're in
that place so yeah that something can be
legal and maybe frowned upon by the
church how do you frame that whole I
think actually I mentioned about
masturbation not porn but uh
masturbation being an example I guess
those things are connected
yeah but let's say so in the Church's
teaching indeed masturbation is seen as
an inadequate incomplete expression of
human sexuality do I recommend therefore
let's legislate against it and send the
police after people know because I might
say be such a huge social negative
impact from that that the acquaintance
principle would clearly hold now porn I
suppose we could have an argument about
that I've been impressed by some of
these recent studies not from a
religious moral perspective but more of
a medical psychological perspective on
the deal it serious effects of porn on
this coming generation you know guys
that have grown up with pornography in a
way that my generation didn't but young
people today starting usually at 11 or
12
studies show and the effects it's having
on them now as they they try to begin
their you know sexual lives has been
problematic you know the objectification
of people involved I can certainly raise
that as a moral issue violence and porn
I could raise as a moral issue so I
don't think that's just free of you know
all moral concern and I think there are
medical psychological issues attached to
it as well that are problematic
now do you press that in a in a legal
direction so I might leave that to the
lawyers and the you know the politicians
yeah so where is that
space where how much influence actually
should if we come from a judeo-christian
foundation here in America which I think
even people that don't like that we do
would would agree that we do yeah
how much room should there be for the
church or the temple or the mosque or
whatever it does to actually influence
policy because I know most my secular
belief would be I would say virtually
none especially if these organizations
want to remain tax-exempt so for example
when the Mormon Church was putting so
much money into fighting gay marriage to
me they're taking a political position
very publicly using money to do it and
at the same time claiming for tax
exemption that's something that I cannot
reconcile and I've never heard a good
argument against that but for you how
much do you feel the church can be
involved while also at the same time
claim you know getting tax-exempt status
which is pretty sweet
yeah the tax-exempt question I'm not
sure I'm ready to talk about that but
generally speaking I would say the
church again not imposing by proposing
within the public space can and should
be a voice and not aggressively so not
using the arm of the state we we don't
have that but arguing making a case
publicly if somebody's my model would be
take Lincoln's second inaugural take
Kings speech in 1819 63 both were people
using religious arguments but in a
public sphere
they weren't sermons but they were
deeply biblical and they were coming up
out of a moral tradition that was that
was biblical and form and they used that
to make a case for political change I
think that should be allowed see I'm
against a liberalism has become
aggressive toward religion and it wants
to exclude it from the public space I
have no quarrel with liberalism it's
classical form I'm opposed to an
aggressive secularism that doesn't want
religion to be a voice in the public
forum I think it can and should be and
I'll take King and Lincoln as my
examples the text same thing I even
thought enough about the tax exemption
thing to to really press it with you but
I'd want us to be a voice I don't think
that's asking too much yeah I certainly
think that's fair I would say every
individual I talk about individual
all the time on the show and I think
every individual has the right to and
furthermore that our arguments don't
have to be couched in explicitly kind of
rationalistic terms Lincoln wasn't
making a purely rationalistic argument
he was relying on the Bible and
appealing to people that knew the Bible
well and I think that should be okay in
the public space King was to making a
public argument for a political change
but he was relying on people's deep
knowledge of the moral teaching of the
Bible to do so and I hope that's always
possible in the American space and I
worry a little bit that an aggressive
liberalism is gonna exclude that yes
that's actually a great way to my next
question have Christians lost something
in that battle the battle we're very
obviously you can make fun of Christians
relentlessly
yeah it's extremely easy you can turn on
some of my favorite shows and we'll talk
about the Simpsons in a second yeah they
can mock Christianity all the time
Family Guy come on Christianity
Southpark my tree today you can mock
Mormonism all the time
if you mock Islam this is a whole other
situation yeah so in a weird way they've
taken Christians tolerance and used it
against them yeah how do you is is this
something did Christianity screw up in a
weird I normally don't know Christianity
and tolerance in the same thing yet the
same time I understand that I live in
this society that's predominantly
Christian and is probably the most
tolerant society yes and that's not
accidental because at its best
toleration comes from deeply biblical
sources I would say and again the stance
of love of the dignity of the individual
a deep suspicion of government I mean
that's right through the Bible I love
that and the American system I think
it's deeply biblical that were
suspicious of our leaders we want to
check them at every turn read 1 Samuel
sometime if you have doubts about that
Israel's approach to Kings you know so I
think that's right that that a lot of
the best of the tradition of Tolerance
comes out of Christianity
here's another side to it at the heart
of our faith in majestically speaking is
a man crucified and not just crucified
but strip naked and exposed to ridicule
so Jesus would have been placed
on this hill near the gate of Jerusalem
and the purpose was to mock him Queen
Cersei in Game of Thrones comes to mind
right that was part of what crucifixion
meant that you were humiliating someone
publicly as they were spitting at him
and they were mocking him that's what we
hold up we don't hide that we hold it up
Jesus crucified Plus as I preached one
thing Christ and him crucified and so in
a certain way there is the ground for
that all right you know yeah throw
garbage at us well our our guy our
Messiah our leader that's how we show
him and so there's there's a mystery
there of God's willingness to endure a
human sin and willingness to take upon
himself negativity and see at their best
to Kings and people like that they got
that that has an enormous power for
social change and so there's a
distinction between Christianity and
Islam where there's you know massive
outrage if the Prophet Mohammed is
displayed in a mocking way we hold them
up hold up the mocked humiliated
crucified Jesus and I do think your
instinct is right that a lot of what's
best in our tradition of Tolerance comes
from that so how much how much is humor
a part of this and now we can also shift
to the Simpsons a little bit okay but I
think you know how much of Judaism is
based in humor yeah any I mean the
gajillion Jewish comic Yeah right
whatever everyone's there's so much it's
about humor so you can make fun of
religion through the lens of you yes
watch it you not only religion but of
historic horrific aliy horrible
historical things that I'm the Holocaust
and all that and Mel Brooks I'm really
David inside bottom right etc etc
Christianity has made it clear that if
you're gonna mock Jesus on television
and movies that it's basically okay in a
weird way or the secularists doing
something dangerous with Islam when they
say we're going to never talk about this
never joke about this never whatever
aren't they actually embolden in the
pieces that are the more radical element
yeah maybe I'm getting into Berkeley
well yeah I can't really speak for Islam
you know maybe that's true but I like
the instinct behind your question I
think is is right
whenever I hear you Mel Brooks or Larry
those people I always think the biblical
prophets I always think all those people
who wrote the Bible you know and the
style of humor and that kind of edgy
ironic a little bit world-weary
nothing's gonna work out I mean now read
the Prophet Jeremiah now read the book
of Job now read the prophet Jonah and
Larry David could have written that book
you know or Melbourne so I like that I
love that it is true it's part of a
biblical perspective a lot of it comes
to from a keen sense of imperfect
ability that's a biblical idea look at a
lot of classical philosophy and here it
has something in common with modern
philosophy both believe in human
perfectibility so Aristotle and Plato
you know just you know learn the forms
and study enough and be right Bradley
educated escape from the cave and you'll
be fine right modern forms of it Marxism
and so on so forth just we make these
requisite economic changes political
adjustments and we'll have the Utopia
religious people coming up out of the
Bible we are always suspicious of that
we are all from the left or the right we
don't like utopianism we think that is a
highly problematic and will lead to the
piling up of corpses which indeed it has
right Pascal's was his great line the
one who would make himself an angel
makes itself obese you know that
whenever you think or if I just make
these adjustments
we'll be fine biblical people are like
yeah okay but I mean in a good Larry
David kind of way like hey and even
including liberal democracy great
I like liberal democracy you know best
or worst of all governments have all the
other ones right but I like it I like
liberal democracy but don't tell me
liberal democracy is gonna uh sure in
the eschaton it's not and it's got all
kinds of problems
Nazism communism Marxism everything the
Bible suspicious of all those isms and I
think that's a great thing even you know
Jesus on the cross again wearing this
crown of thorns with a sign over his
head that was put there by the Roman
governor talk about you know the Roman
Empire boy we're gonna solve his problem
just submit to us you'll be fine and
it's a mockery the cross is meant to be
is it's held up as a mockery to the
world and that Pilate deliciously put on
the
cross Jesus Nazareth King of the Jews
thereby undermining himself you know so
I love that side of biblical religion
we're we're like Larry David we're a
skeptical of a lot of societal forms you
know hmm
so from Larry David now finally did the
same so you talked about the Homer
Simpson ization oh yeah yeah right and I
love this because you your basic
argument is that Homer came around and
he was sort of this kind of dullard
trying to do well but incompetent and
his wife Marge was the stickler and the
whatever and I used to talk about this
in stand-up that this sort of this idea
eventually ruined comedy I love the
Simpsons so much of what I believe and
and satire came from The Simpsons
especially those early years but then
there was this like cloning of shows
yeah where every male character was this
right apt [ __ ] who didn't know what was
going on and the woman was secretly
pulling the strings or telling the guy
he was an 88 or something yeah what
what's the net effect what is it about
this that bothers you
yeah and of course I agree with you too
I love the Simpsons I watch them for
years and I can quote Simpsons lines it
links me to a lot of people I love The
Simpsons is the best written show on
television all that yeah what oh yeah
wonderful right yes and no religion
watch when God appears in the Senate
it's always it's always interesting when
God appears in the Simpsons and also
unlike almost every other show in
America everyone goes to church on
Sunday in the Simpsons the whole the
whole town mr. burns they're all in
church Sunday you know procrustean up
who I think is it but I love window
there's a ladder Abbot Jackie Mason
played Krusty's father the rabbi you
know yeah so I mean they're they're
great on religion God has those got if
it has the five fingers the other ones
always like remember the one where God
is like a beam of light he's chasing
home with a car and then it jumps a
train track and the trains going by and
then God goes I'm too old and you know
no God always comes comes across pretty
well in the Simpsons yeah but what was
bugging me and what you're referring to
is this almost demonization of men you
know that men are as you say it's
bumblers and incompetent and it's the
women I have all the gifts
and remember the episode when Lisa is so
worried that she's inherited some
terrible thing from her family but in
fact the stupid gene is on the male side
and you know the female Simpsons are all
brains okay but my fear is that and then
I extrapolate from that to a lot of
things in the popular culture where you
see the same dynamic I worry about young
men in our culture that imbibed that
message of kind of inferiority and I
want to say you know you go boy as much
as you go girl and give the boys a sense
of of their purpose it doesn't have to
stand to thwart women doesn't have to be
in an oppressive relationship but I want
men to feel as you know empowered and
all that and I do worry a little bit
about younger men and you see it in the
in the literature of the psychologists
we'll talk about as I deal with young
men this sense of inferiority so that's
why I was complaining about there but
generally I love the Simpsons yeah I
feel like the Simpsons is the right way
to end this yeah good except that as we
as proper ending well I've thoroughly
enjoyed this and I think this was really
what the spirit of what I tried in
spirit but unintended of what I try to
do here I think we did pretty well and I
loved it and that's what it's all about
so we'll do it again sometime because I
love that there's a lot more I didn't
get me all right well I want to thank
Bishop Baron for joining me today and
you can follow him on the Twitter at
Bishop Baron and check out his website
word on fire org
[Music]
you